The final trailer for Rogue One: A Star Wars
Story has arrived, and it finally pulls back
the curtain on exactly what fans can expect
from the franchise's first spinoff story.
Just for you, we watched it 50 times and kept
our eyes peeled for things you might have
missed in the new Rogue One trailer...
Father-daughter story
With all the jump cuts and mood lighting,
you might have actually missed the central
thrust of the trailer, which is that the whole
thing really boils down to a father-daughter
story, which is sort of familiar territory
for this whole Star Wars thing...
"Say you understand"
"I understand"
When Jyn's father Galen is seized by Stormtroopers,
she's left behind to fend for herself.
But when the Rebels free her years later,
it turns out Dad is, in fact, working for
the Empire to create the Death Star.
Can they stop the Death Star and save Daddy
at the same time?
"We need to find him!"
We'll find out!
That's one big statue
Unlike the main Star Wars Saga films, Rogue
One is not expected to feature any Jedi in
a meaningful way, Darth Vader excluded.
Instead, this has been pitched as a story
of regular folks taking on the big, bad Empire.
But this gorgeous shot of a U-Wing ship flying
over the remnants of a massive fallen Jedi
statue shows their influence is still part
of this larger world.
Hmm....
Darth Vader looms large
Speaking of Darth Vader, the new footage here
finally shows him in action, suggesting he
may play a bigger role than previously expected.
Could Vader's confrontation with Imperial
bad guy Director Krennic happen after the
Rebel team inflicts some damage on the Death
Star project?
Ship shape
We weren't sure until now what "Rogue One"
actually meant.
Director Gareth Edwards had previously told
Empire magazine that the film's title was
more of a metaphor for the project itself,
as the first spinoff film not following known
characters like Luke, Leia, and the rest of
the gang.
But on-screen?
We learn that it's also the impromptu call
sign they come up with for their ship during
the mission.
"Rogue...Rogue One."
It feels more Hope-ful
It's no secret the film went back in for extensive
reshoots a few months before its December
2016 release date, with rumors swirling that
Disney wanted the film to look and feel more
upbeat and hopeful.
"Take hold of this moment!"
And this attitude shows in the trailer, which
has a vibe much closer to that of the original
Star Wars: A New Hope.
Sure, it's an us-against-the-world story,
but the Rebels do still believe they can win.
"Rebellions are built on hope!"
The team goes undercover as Imperial officers
One fleeting shot shows Jyn and other members
of her Rebel strike team disguised as Imperial
officers.
Could this be the moment where they first
break into the Imperial stronghold to find
Galen?
Also, for fans of the original trilogy, the
undercover move is a classic tactic to access
Empire facilities.
"I can't see a thing in this helmet!"
Nice callback.
"Aren't you a little short for a stormtrooper?"
"Huh?
Oh the uniform."
See Saw
Forest Whitaker is playing a mysterious man
who should be very familiar to fans of Star
Wars: The Clone Wars...
"Who are you?"
"I'm Saw Gerrera."
It's true: Whitaker has been confirmed as
Saw Gerrera, a rebel hero.
Bringing in the character marks Star Wars'
first major crossover from the TV show to
film, and not the other way around.
Gerrera was introduced in The Clone Wars animated
series as a young man.
Now, years later, Saw is all grown up and
live-action in Rogue One.
Awesome.
Alienation
It wouldn't be a Star Wars movie if we didn't
get to meet a few new alien species, but this
design certainly looks like it was pulled
from Mad Max: Fury Road director George Miller's
sketchbook.
Despite the Immortan Joe vibe, though, this
alien named Edrio Two-Tubes is actually an
ally of Saw Gerrera.
We're glad he's on our side...
Space Fights
The Force Awakens was pretty great, but it
was lacking in one key area: space battles.
That looks to change in Rogue One.
The footage here shows a fleet of X-Wings
attacking a large Imperial ship in space.
Finally: Rogue One is putting the star wars
back in Star Wars.
Birth of the Rebellion
The Rebel planning scenes like the one here
echo the feel of the original trilogy, and
for good reason.
Before the Rebellion took the Empire head-on
in A New Hope, these disparate Rebel leaders
were figuring out how to join forces for their
first major mission.
In other words, we're finally bearing witness
to the birth of the Rebellion as we first
knew it.
"Make 10 men feel like a hundred"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think of the Rogue One trailer...